let's play in the Metroid Prime remaster
sniffing around doing that end game
cleanup hadn't run across a save point
in about an hour
and I died
all that progress all that work
gone
new games have made me soft
anywho there's new remake of Children of
the Corn did you know about that
probably not I don't think a lot of
people did which is why we need to talk
about it because sometimes it's
important
to take out the trash
[Music]
so Children of the Corn is another
remake of an old film or you can see it
as a new Stephen King adaptation so
prefacing I haven't seen Children of the
Corn I thought I did and I was like oh
yeah the one where the kid gets sucked
into the wood chipper at the end oh that
was two so I've seen two and three
stirring a marathon in the 90s I guess I
missed one but hey them's the times so I
haven't seen the original haven't read
the book I don't know how this Stacks up
I just know how this movie Stacks up in
terms of its own film and whether or not
it's entertaining funny thing this movie
wastes no time it it gets to it it's
just like this little girl's like you
know what adult's gonna die today
usually I appreciate it when a film can
just get to it and not waste your time
but this is the kind of film that gets
right to it and still feels like it's
wasting your time this movie needed a
lot more Intrigue a lot more character
development like let's have some time to
get to know these people before things
just fall apart when I didn't get that
in here I was met with that feeling I
usually get in Stephen King adaptations
which is this would be a much better
mini series of some sort it's actually
funny enough it felt like a mini series
that was cut down to about an hour and a
half an hour 45 minute film what you
think that's going to look like this is
exactly that there were some things in
this film where I'm like I
I can almost see what you were going for
there which means it was probably done
better in the book and if it wasn't well
hey this movie came dangerously close to
making sense it was when I was met with
those feelings of I'm sure there's some
sort of allegory of people versus
Twitter on here maybe I'm just seeing
what I want to say
I would totally die in this Children of
the Corn story wouldn't I that I'd be
one of the adults they put in the pit
and Berry our two leads make the best
attempt at giving us something in fact
uh the creepy girl Kate Moyer I believe
that's her name yep Kate Moyer I felt
she did a really good job at playing a
creepy girl I would like to see her have
a shot at doing that in a movie with a
better script for her to work with and
this is where I'm going to give you a
light spot spoiler warning sure I'm
going to talk about the big CGI thing at
the end
are you still gonna see this movie you
can all I can do is give you my opinion
what you do with that opinion that is
yours to do with as you will that says
life should be but if you are going to
see this movie
blink twice if you're in trouble
right so this little girl in this movie
is killing the adults to appease this I
don't know this being that she calls He
Who Walks you don't really know what it
is see a couple times like you know a
plant-looking hand you might hear a
sound maybe you'll see the corn stalks
moving you're like oh something's there
which works that was any and all
Intrigue in this movie was based around
that I'm like what is this thing what is
what's going on then for the climax of
this film you see the big evil group
corn stock CGI monster and I was like
Jaws you should have done the Jaws
famously the story of the film Jaws is
they couldn't get the shark to look
right so Spielberg was like all right we
just won't show the shark for most of
the movie it worked out better for the
films like the textbook case of making
lemonade out of lemons that's also
applicable to bad CGI if you can't make
the CGI look good just don't show the
thing because any of the Intrigue I had
was wrapped around this monster I
thought was kind of cool you never
really saw the monster and then you see
the monster
and any and all we're talking all
all all
all Intrigue was gone and then it was
our lead versus big CGI corn stock
monster thing and it was terrible funny
enough you ever go on a long drive
through ironically farmland or a desert
just basically long stretches of flat
land and you do it for a while long
enough to feel like you're going about
20 miles an hour but you're really going
75 right you're moving fast but it
barely feels like you're moving at all
that's what this movie feels like a lot
of [__] happens very quickly but there's
no real attempt at getting the audience
to care about the characters or having
some narrative thread that weaves it
together so it feels like nothing's
happening you get glimpses of what looks
like could have been a good movie there
and it's almost as though the film makes
a conscious effort to avoid that the
Children of the Corn remake is
dog [__] this movie committed not a
cardinal sin but the cardinal sin it was
just boring alright so Children of the
Corn what's your favorite Children of
the Corn movie I'm not even gonna
impress you with a question that implies
that you need to watch this and tell me
what you thought of this one also
favorite Children of the Corn movie
Whatever let's just have some fun with
it whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]